pour moi il y avait énormément de monde
j'ai l'habitude de faire des
manifestations
j'ai mis trois heures pour aller de
bercy à la bastille en marchant un en
piétinant aussi parfois et donc non non
il y avait il y avait du monde oui parce
que la manifestation de jeudi selon vous
savez être enfin le lancement du grand
mouvement social que la gauche radicale
alternative à l'emploi comme on veut
n'est pas parvenu à lancer au moment de
la réforme du code du travail
donc d'abord enfin les mouvements
sociaux personne n'a de un bouton sur
lequel appuyer là c'est moi ce que j'ai
constaté hier c'est jeu c'est une
convergence
j'ai vu des avocats des filets à côté de
fonctionnaire de préfecture puis
d'infirmières et de médecins d'hôpitaux
de cheminots enfin bref c'est ce
sentiment que ce gouvernement s'attaque
aux services publics et les services
publics dans un pays comme la france
c'est la république et que quand on
affaiblit les services publics ont
affaibli la république parce que telle
est notre histoire
telle est notre pays et elle est la
force de ce pays de 2,2 de garantir une
certaine égalité d'accès à des biens qui
sont vitaux et de absolument nécessaire
donc republic services publics
et là je crois qu'il ya un élément de
convergence très fort puisque vous étiez
dans le cortège vous l'avez dit vous
avez constaté que le parti socialiste a
été hué le pcf auquel vous appartenez a
été plutôt discret en revanche lui qui a
été acclamé hier c'était jean luc
mélenchon est ce qu'aujourd'hui c'est la
france insoumise qui captent qui
incarnent les revendications sociales du
pays selon vous que le parti socialiste
se fassent tuer
bon je trouve ça dommage pour ce qui me
concerne
bon en même temps caen
on a fait pendant cinq ans la politique
qu'ils ont fait de 2012 à 2017 il
fallait pas s'attendre non plus olivier
faur l'a dit lui même je m'attendais pas
à être reçu avec un tapis rouge bon
enfin les gens il aura peu de mémoire
quand même donc il va falloir faire un
peu plus de preuve de sens un véritable
opposition et 2 puis aussi de son propre
réflexion sur les cinq années de
françois hollande
après si vous voulez moi je faut faire
attention les gens n'ont pas envie de
récupération politique
moi j'ai aussi quand j'ai vu ma
carnation pas de récupération mais n'a
guère nation ou même de captation et
d'incarner même d'incarnation l'ailé moi
j'ai vu des gens qui ont envie de ce
saint carné ou de se retrouver dans aux
angles aucun aucune formation politique
où aucun leader en particulier j'ai
surtout vu des gens qui veulent tout
faire pour être le plus nombreux
possible à résister à cette ses attaques
contre notre pays et notre république
parmi ces gens il y en a un qui fait un
peu son retour médiatique c'est olivier
besancenot n'avait pas vu depuis un
moment qu'est ce que ça peut apporter
selon vous à votre combat la présence le
retour d'olivier besancenot qui a une
personnalité médiatique connu et reconnu
il est d'après midi les revenus et parce
qu'il a une parole forte de bon sens
veut mon point de vue c'est celle de
l'unité d'art que quand on est face à
des rouleaux compresseurs comme celui du
gouvernement macron avec une loi tous
les deux jours essayé d'étourdir comme
on est ourdi un canard avant de
l'assommer
on essaye d'étourdir le pays par une
avalanche de loi et essayer de faire
perdre le sens est bon se dire il faut
se rassembler chacun doit sortir de ces
postures un peu individuel ou partisane
c'était une voix et une direction de bon
sens olivier besancenot la porte et il a
eu raison
et je m'en félicite